hmm okay baybay and we're gonna play
this game called sheltered okay okay
baybay well we're gonna play this game
now that I'm done with my dance lessons
and I can really just sit down um so
anyway this game is an early access came
it's um I'm sure Sheldon sheltered and
to be honest this is going to be
actually my second recording because the
first recording I encountered a huge
error in the game basically and a lot of
people are complaining discussions
obviously tell you about it when you get
there but this way want to be in the
tutorial and it actually would not be a
shitty thing so basically there is an
apocalypse and you are now in the
[ __ ] wasteland so I want to make
these dudes real quick this dude is
gonna be a [ __ ] badass mofo um let's
say here let's see here let's see here
how God got get um oh he's gonna be real
cool oh he shirt actually has to be more
Oh more badass than that who that is
very nice very nice i would i would talk
to him at the club oh oh yes yes and the
pants um the pants gotta be actually i
need i need something like tighter like
something like hello like people like
i'm here to save you like if you need my
help just ask commando yes oh baby make
this brown or like camo colored
oh [ __ ] yes courageous is the type in a
staff preset we're gonna make this [ __ ]
a violent criminal okay well eyelet um
okay a good good good in the name isn't
Sarah the name is Hong Kong okay the
next one is ah I gotta have this Patrick
guy here to like um okay I'll make like
his female but I'm gonna make her
Shannon I'm with a big M because she is
a killer okay and I gotta make her
equally [ __ ] up so sore her traits are
gonna be not optimistic resourceful but
I'm gonna make her like [ __ ] troubled
okay and because she's troubled her legs
are like [ __ ] up you know like say
look yeah I [ __ ] up they're black
they're black in the top color actually
I need a more body type um it needs to
be like hello like I come to kill oh
good good guess she's come to kill but
the top isn't like deadly enough that
red is block stop that guy that's good
oh [ __ ] hair that is not a good hair for
combat so um we gonna make it like
deadly I would say yeah that's a deadly
luck dad Layla got get kick it hair
color it's gotta be black as the night
okay actually not anymore that's good
that's good okay um resourceful and
troubled she is self troubled of skin
color it's make it really white like
really why I like like consider the dark
light there right there right now it's
like pink ah
okay I got get again okay um now little
Harold he's gonna be like our genius
okay like smarty pants cuz he's going to
be working very hard okay um it's a top
color like make him a little academic
like we have little academic kids the
hair is [ __ ] awful so let's change
that as well now he's gonna be like a
good boy like a good boy with like a
good like upbringing uh yes guys guys
like and pants no shorts okay this may
be the apocalypse but you know like you
got to be a good boy so where it likes
needs something fancy gud gud i need i
need like slacks for him if that works
good where is any a nice little jacket
oh god got a top color make it a nice
little very nice like yellow i think i
need to look professional hey blow I
guess mm death this is good this is good
and this is little Nicholas okay Oh
traits um he is just like a he is a
let's see here proactive you know I like
these types and let's have a little girl
her name is a little little little Cindy
Lou but strange like le da bo and I not
that L oh yeah thing you know I so Cindy
low okay and I'm she's very poor ok so
we're going to give her some very poor
like broken [ __ ] I guess that's fine I'm
shirt let's see
like you could say like it's nice but
it's like dirty like so sorry hair color
like yellow air like red i guess like
yeah she's kind of like adopted we don't
really talk about it but we know like I
was used to know it all yes as well
traits actually she's actually hands-on
she has to have like the best like
education okay and faster pace ooh
there's a lot of work dog is good cat is
good feeding every other day stress
reduction no snake skeet right away
while the snake is out of event no rats
will come to shelter beware its buddy I
don't want to [ __ ] worry the cats the
gut the cats get and the cat's name is
Tucker the third because I had two other
suckers what a rough parents but good
kids okay so we're going to do this
we're not going to play the toro because
i'm too good for this and we're going to
do this every week week by week of the
day's going too fast and some days I'm a
fast forward [ __ ] so let's say this
let's see this okay oh good good good
okay so the first order of business
while this guy is healthy I want to set
up an expedition he's going by himself
Oh farm
I hope do the school he needs one of
these equipped equipped was that cold ok
we have like a different assortment of
stuff circuit breaker puck we've no
[ __ ] hinges yes this [ __ ] has to go
out yep she'll go to the forum and you
want to give her a weapon in this and
just send this [ __ ] away now these guys
you want them to start working lock in
fast upgrade this [ __ ] a level two I
hear me fart um and how it feels in
their fuel fuel fuel [ __ ] um where is
her cat oh there it is you see the cat
and trick is you do not want to feed the
animals until they are hungry because
basically they just keep on either the
good dog Oh real transmission except yes
search it okay um fix this
oh except the transmission here stumbled
yes social look brain on surface was
good so it's collecting water okay it's
going well it's going well except
together you see the items if I can just
take all of it basically we need some
mint gas masks yes cuz that's what's
getting crazy you don't really need pain
because I think you start with a lot of
pain circuit board and I've got a nail
I've confirmed yes okay basically the
problem is when I made a snare trap you
can't store the meat unless you have a
fridge and that's [ __ ] annoying as
[ __ ] Oh hinge hinges are like insanely
important you have coal already water
food rope [ __ ] do we have rubber [ __ ] we
don't really need coal let's just make
sure we have rubber and based on my
family's like a starving and have like a
bunch of [ __ ] food up here and like
you can kill a mouse but you can't be
[ __ ] to eat it you know it's like
[ __ ] up so and a lot of my so you
might as well just keep the cat you like
for you to every other day I didn't
really encounter much much more got some
to a little Cindy Lou
Oh shet anyone more hinge oh no he has
the end he has the hinge okay okay yeah
you basically really [ __ ] want to get
that [ __ ] right away like I started
making spaces and water storages but I
[ __ ] starving in week two it was it
was a really slow drawn-out death
everyone wasn't happy about it I think
take all yes she can actually make a bed
because I don't really would a nylon I'm
just make sure it doesn't interfere wood
and I'm yep no it doesn't so make one of
these guys not a lot of space in the
beginning but that's okay this is kind
of good yeah so this guy should just
[ __ ] go out there again this time go
to the church yeah got it clipped
equipped yes yes I'm very ready to
where's that little boy good good ooh
take it all
there's that little boy Nicholas dropped
an item for daddy oh oh [ __ ] I need a
[ __ ] motor hmm any more motors pocket
[ __ ] um okay well work on on the future
this [ __ ] got to go back out there that
go oh [ __ ] you hungry [ __ ] yes okay
hunger eight get tired now now now you
can probably make a bathroom then in the
meantime or a shower metal bucket nail
well I just want to make sure i'm not i
really need this middle too and that's
it okay make one of these showers okay
now this [ __ ] you better go back out
there
quipped equipped go go go this [ __ ] can
probably make another water bucket oh
[ __ ] search it yep I don't know why they
tell them to go there i don't know why
they [ __ ] to say like I should i
search it this guy should probably drink
the water while you can and then she
should probably drink the water right
after that
this guy should probably add fuel you
don't you really feel for everything
else except a person in the trash truck
it Bouchette come on oh good good good
well I'm trait I don't need a mouth to
feed okay
well it wasn't dangerous i'll [ __ ] it
you see me see good great think green
atoms are like very useful Oh food I
[ __ ] need that this stuff for
crafting good um she should probably
make it she should probably sleep
actually this guy should probably make
it toilet bucket would okay good going
to make sure not too crazy here the
thing that's so annoying is really like
beds take up so much room because you
can't cope can't go like this way it's
like spread out so that's why I'm a
another room pretty quick the beginning
lumber yard uh yeah I think eventually
start learning like what's what
after she's done I want her to broadcast
for traders I got a recruiting beginning
was pretty cool but then it's like okay
and I really need food okay we got a lot
on the one which is good yes ok this is
[ __ ] good just gonna eat and get
involved good I think it's like they
probably make it coming I don't know
they could be dangerous oh [ __ ] the
governor uh-oh
[ __ ] fight them that'd be cool attack
um melee what the [ __ ] is going on here
what what the [ __ ] are you doing ow oh
ok escape
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] pick up
escape [ __ ] escape good good okay I
lost all the help but [ __ ] it
Chris location that was good good yeah
okay so guys going back out oh [ __ ] ooh
ok he could do it equipped equipped
drive empty cans I could give him no
bucket let's get to it [ __ ] eat [ __ ]
Oh is she good yeah she's almost good
that's for tiny bit examine items we can
use water hatchets are good
how's that
yeah okay good we are doing really good
for day two now it doesn't seem that way
but we are wait i know that [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] who is this Sarah oh [ __ ] yes ah
buck cement you need cement for making
rooms and that's actually pretty good so
um I need a pocket battery [ __ ] you
traitor [ __ ] lucky they're not that
smart mmm you feel any metal [ __ ] um and
jazz empty can [ __ ] how much would they
give me great that's good
okay you don't need that [ __ ]
let us see [ __ ] what is thi yet ooh in
the road I can't eat a motor okay let's
see what's going on here yes
[ __ ] I don't got anything
ok
that was almost violent do I did
we'll use a toilet this [ __ ] gotta go
to sleep it's my house yep you can kind
of tell what you're going to find
idolized [ __ ] laptop [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
take it cuz you never know it could take
the stuff cause you can always swap it
out later alright so I'm alert again oh
[ __ ] it's much more like a neighborhood
i'm at this guy needs to take a [ __ ]
haha it's gonna take a shower use toilet
now
come on you [ __ ] hands a petrol
station yeah okay
okay this [ __ ] can wake up
it's kind of good to put the stuff on
home now the expedition to I don't go
into the woods here I don't know what
the [ __ ] that is [ __ ] on of water
eight and 595 ok she can just show the
intercom then dammit items
I don't need this okay I think it's
[ __ ] come back now where is the cat
stinger wit de fog a thorough exam and
examine [ __ ] hey there's no room for
that need mental 10 empty can with the
[ __ ]
okay Oh set off [ __ ] hinge oh we're
not even [ __ ] fed okay this bitch's
gotta get home um so we're gonna feed
this cat she can actually I don't know
what the [ __ ] she can do
Akon I just need this guy to come home
k gone [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Gabe gone
it's too far hello oh oh oh [ __ ] okay
what the [ __ ] do you want for this what
give you [ __ ] would you want some
petrol yes Daddy like a okay so we got
the kids to work yet I still need a
[ __ ] motor I can make us another room
a strike recycling at the fuel
his sugar boy is not gonna happen spike
trap shyt part of our MIT [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] I can't get a motor trip wire
would nylon eyes will make it [ __ ]
wonder if I can make another space yes
wood metal cement let me just make sure
I don't [ __ ] around with that one man so
that okay I'll make some more room yep
yes nice and far away and this [ __ ] can
wake up probably
cropped an item
makes it shower that's a toilet [ __ ]
with shower
all right there [ __ ] conduct come on
[ __ ] 81 we're gonna put this [ __ ]
like escape mmm sure
okay and I confirm this guy this girl
can make a shower right there get get
get um and also in the meantime they can
just like fix [ __ ] so like Tegrity 73
twenty-nine percent uh I need a motor I
can't you I don't need a [ __ ] hatchet
no I don't need this stuff
water kimchi love he's gotta wait for it
to rain what if she can crap the medium
bucket rubber
ok ok what here's [ __ ]
look for some [ __ ] don't need this [ __ ]
and probably don't need no [ __ ] sand
okay good right at fuel there's that
Jennifer I'll kill that [ __ ] huncle
without uncle Chet how the [ __ ] do i get
rid of food poisoning um I don't know
how shower there's a fox at the door
respond hmm yes okay it's a little
strange but alright we have we no
[ __ ] water so I can't set up an
expedition Jennifer
remember we can let Jennifer died so she
can do dirty work yeah the guy that
looking to get cubers huncle he need to
take a [ __ ] shower Cindy Lou or yet
where are you at oh [ __ ] I was the one
[ __ ] sleeping right now who's this
[ __ ] get out of here oh it's Shannon
get get um [ __ ] this lady has to
basically broadcast basically 24 7
actually no let's get him Shan it
through that no Jennifer in the meantime
I can probably make another bet buck
anymore nylon [ __ ] this guy's not doing
so good huncle so you can probably go
down there and just stay down there
she'll turn up we'll put this down here
trying to make as much space as possible
get
we had some fuel we got no [ __ ] water
that's good that's good storage of that
maximum capacity make a storage unit
wood and nail and then she could take a
shower after that get good kid speed up
some [ __ ] here like a hero some people
catch if you can use a shower why don't
you say so good Oh take this nylon off
yeah switch no maybe I use this [ __ ] it
trade what do I have like a lot of okay
oh [ __ ] that I want to make
all right do you need snare trap up
there by this [ __ ] better put on some
suits and then she can resume that
cut item time make another storage box
yeah okay
this guy is really just not looking good
Oh day five okay this guy is exhaust
who's exhausted let's go get not yet oh
good good god oh my crafts another bed
craft that's what I couldn't do before
you're probably [ __ ] need that she's
fine how much food we got left oh god no
food no fit so sorry cat but we have
water though [ __ ] um sure let me find
someone who can go out there Nicholas oh
[ __ ] no Shannon and uncle suck okay sure
uncle you had to wait the [ __ ] off take
a shower
fix fix fix to [ __ ] that psychopath
ok
I don't know how long that guy's gonna
be out there for this guy's good though
so what a setup expedition to yes nope
we have no water that we had a [ __ ] ton
of water okay now i cant a good
okay Jenna first to go the bathroom use
toilet this guy should broadcast for
traders no longer food poisoning good
peeps I got thirsty I don't think we
have water for that do we yeah there's
no water [ __ ] I can see the person s yes
ooh looks like we got what we needed
battery yeah yet you want some coal
battery yeah yeah craft the [ __ ] item
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] where the [ __ ] can I put this
do you [ __ ] [ __ ] you take up all
the [ __ ] in a row
okay house it's gonna this guy can
probably cut that [ __ ] out come on come
on not dying to go the toilet she's a
toilet oh [ __ ] you can't [ __ ] use a
toilet if you know water that is so
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] bucket toilet bucket
toilet
this guy harvest that trap go go go go
yeah me who's the guy that really has to
eat this dude okay good good hong kong's
food poisoning he always has food
poisoning okay yeah what's [ __ ] get
pressure go to sleep okay we're doing
good gee that was probably by far the
hardest part um can one of the kids were
the kids at one of these kids
can I make another or kind make the
grill yes yes
we're the kids Cindy Lou was kind of
[ __ ] up she should watch it out [ __ ]
can she even wash it out without
Nicholas make this and they wrecked
sleep okay please finish this day and
week one is complete Cindy Lou [ __ ]
Cindy Lou you got that food poisoning go
ya got that 50 / [ __ ] rain respond
yes do you need a circuit board hmm
yeah everyone is getting quite thirsty
okay um me a bucket because we [ __ ]
need water
oh [ __ ]
hmm oh yeah the kid Cindy Lou Nicholas
is where's Nicholas house sleeping [ __ ]
no no he's a big one
s we need [ __ ] water all we need it's
just some right oxygen Shannon fix this
yeah hey Dan guess not doing too good
jets get the [ __ ] rabbit away I need
another rope Monza's gotta rein it just
got a rain all right day 8 we're going
to pause it right there and we see if we
[ __ ] it and make it two three [ __ ] is
getting bad